what's happening reject nation look who
i got back with me today
ashley the ender how you doing ashley
i'm good how are you doing doing great
we are filming this the day
after day one of election day she's
actually
has to take a flight out uh but tomorrow
in a couple days a couple days can't say
what for
but it's something pretty exciting that
maybe i could tell you guys later on is
that fine
that's fine that's all i can say that's
it that's awesome that's all there
sizzle not the steak swing on by help me
film a few videos so ashley have you
seen
this channel ever i doubt you have
because you don't watch as much youtube
and me
shame on you i came here to insult you
epic rap battles of history no well
i'm not going to tell you anything more
you've heard rap before right
i have i know eminem this is so wow
eminem macklemore no i see you know all
the grits i won't say anything this is
called the joker versus pennywise
ooh i already like it yeah i know you
would
and actually this video came out uh
almost
one year ago exactly oh wow and as a fan
of the pennywise character and of course
joker was like i think it's about time i
finally
watch this oh this is your first time
watching it yes it's a reaction oh yes
yes
okay i thought it was just a reaction i
just wanted to show you
that's great makeup
[Music]
it down
[Music]
balloons [ __ ]
[Music]
hmm
or i will spend the whole week
[Music]
good
[Music]
wow
wow wow
that was pretty good isn't that
impressive that was really cool
impressive wow so for this channel do
they usually take like
two famous people and they battle each
other like this yeah it could be like
historical figures they recently did
trump versus biden and they usually do a
lot of movie characters as well
oh i like it they do a whole bunch it
can get pretty
addicting to say the least yeah that's
fun
yeah who won do you think in my opinion
oh man you know
i'm biased against for the joker like
i'm like i have a bias
however i feel like based off of
the the battle the arguments laid out
yeah i guess i would have to say
pennywise do you think he won okay yeah
this is what i think
all right or no you go no no no no tell
the audience what you think
i think that the joker won as far
as like his lines that he had okay
but i think that penny weiss won with
creepiness
the way that they have his voice and the
things that they did like while he was
rapping i feel like
he still creeps me out more than the
joker sure but i feel like
the rap battle itself would probably go
to the joker
okay that's what i think honestly i
think sometimes my mind can get swayed
by just whoever went last
which is kind of an unfair thing to do
because whoever goes last is the person
who went second
right and just structurally speaking
perhaps you're right it's something i'd
have to examine a little bit more but i
just thought he laid down some great
points about who
but then again you know thinking about
what joker said about who's beat
pennywise in the past
you know i might have to change my vote
i changed my vote
i've convinced him joker won you should
get into politics ashley
man you really did convince me but
pennywise is creepier don't you think
yeah i think what's really great about
what they do with epic rap battles in
particular
especially this one as like iconic of
characters as they are and then they
have like the arkham asylum and then all
the different motifs that you saw of
pennywise
mouth alien thing you know the dancing
clown stuff all the different production
designs and visual effects
i feel like they really brought that to
life here and especially for the
pennywise department
i thought it looked incredible i thought
it looked really good like this looks
straight out of the movie yeah at
certain points
yeah and then like the thing when he
does like that dance thing you know
things like moving behind him i thought
that was really cool and he looks
almost exactly like him like pennywise a
lot like him yeah
you would swear they got the actual it's
more than just getting the makeup right
i mean you could put the makeup you got
the mannerisms and like the tone of the
voice was really close i thought too
oh my god i completely agree with you
i'm so glad i could introduce them to
you so this came out before
or after the joker with joaquin phoenix
this came out
no that one came out in october
so this came out of november last year
so it's it's a little bit after
i think that's what that line was
referencing that pennywise says the
joker about how you're just sad
well the thing that i think that the
joker has over pennywise is that penny
weiss only gets to like
come out on every what 27 years
you know you might be right about i
think so so like he doesn't have as much
time to like be evil
yeah yeah you know what i mean like the
joker like kind of consistently stays
evil but the
the pennywise only has like a little bit
of moan like a little bit of time to
shine
and at the end of the day yeah i think
uh pennywise does get defeated how about
serious we're taking this argument
yeah yeah he gets he gets taken out
pretty easily
all things considered i mean last movie
he got taken out by just being called
clown
yeah well the last movie the first movie
i loved
yeah i liked the line about the ninja
turtle thing i thought that was a great
liar
in the sewer i thought that was really
joker one i don't know what i was
thinking
ashley you are correct once again i'm
very proud to have your assessment
skills here
guys do actually a big solid favor she
really needs this
more than anything else in her life
right now she really wants to increase
her social media following
oh yeah she hits me up all the time
saying greg how can i get more instagram
followers and i'm like
i don't know
your likes and all those things do it
today
yeah that doesn't make sense subscribe
to the real rejects
click that notification bell subscribe
to epic rap battles
hit the like button youtube things that
people say on youtube
last but not least
i want to give one today to a man named
jean jeter
who's been a long time follower of our
channel wonderful supporter over at our
patreon page today
and he recently launched a new book and
it's called the craigslist model let me
read the description off of
amazon for you guys where you can buy
the book it's the job of the
photographer to capture a moment with a
lonesome medium
a photographer can meet and photograph
people from all walks of life
throughout slade west's life as a
photographer he has often asked who this
is the craziest model that he ever
worked with
the one he met on craigslist like how i
met alyssa ferrari
her name was karen zoom based on the
idiocy of
kaileen juan zhang and
it's also available on apple books
google books and smash words as well
jean we're constantly crediting you for
being so creative and experimenting and
trying out new things
all the time you can check out his
instagram page where he photographs a
lot of beautiful people as well
guys if you're interested it's free on
kindle on amazon you can buy the book on
paperback
craigslist model get it today we'll
probably do a community post about it
later this month
check it out gotta read it myself thanks
guys
[Music]
you